بينما أكون محادثة في LC Calvin ooh ،
نحن هنا اليوم لمقابلة المالكين
للتحدث عما يفعلونه في
الوقت الحالي
[موسيقى]
الطيور على chokolate هي شراء أول
مصنع شوكولاتة من الفول إلى البار
وهم في الأساس  أحضر لك
حبوب الشوكولاتة الطازجة من جميع أنحاء
العالم وأحضرها إلى الكوس وقاموا بتحميصها وتحويلها إلى
علبة شوكولاتة جميلة.
تجربة للذهاب
ومعرفة كيف تتم العملية.
من الخلف إلى الأمام
في السنوات الخمس إلى الست الماضية ،
انفجر الحرفي الذي تعرفه مشهد إنتاج الطعام في دبي للتو ، لقد
رأينا الكثير من رواد الأعمال الشباب
مع الطهاة وهم يصنعون
أشياء مثيرة للاهتمام تعرف أنها
التغيير  في المدينة وكم عدد
الأنواع المختلفة من المنتجات التي
تصنعها بالفعل لدينا 30 قطعة شوكولاتة مختلفة
الآن ، لذا فهذه الشوكولاتة البيضاء
مميزة والقرفة وهناك ميشيل
ثم جزء منك بعتني في هذا
واحد هذا سيصبح مثل  المفضل لدي
على وجه اليقين بشأن ELQ والذي يتمثل في
كونه مركزيًا للغاية ، فهو مختلف تمامًا ،
مثل أن المشهد الإبداعي في دبي
يأتي من العدم
وهناك أشياء رائعة تحدث هنا كما
قلت إنها تتعلق بالصناع والحرفيين
إنه مبدع